I own people welcome to the report I'm
Dave Rubin I've got back troutman Jimmy
door
with me let's jump into nukes because
President Obama yesterday
said that his biggest worry is in russia
it's actually that a nuclear bomb
my co-op in New York City I moved from
New York bad a year ago so I'm going
pretty good about this
but not only that but just a couple days
ago in the Netherlands a group of world
leaders got together to play some
nuclear war games to
its or to figure out the planning and
preparation and
fallout no pun intended if a nuclear
bomb was to go off
in a major metropolitan areas for each
world leader had a computer tablet with
touch screen options to make
100 more responses to a series of poor
scenario films played out by actor so
they literally were watching actors
act out this the situation in the war
game a terrorist attack with anatomic
dirty bomb takes place in the financial
heartburn
unnamed but Western metropolis this is
probably New York if it's in the case
the United States and in a competitive
environment with the ticking clock the
world leaders had to make rapid choices
before the results were presented to the
group
followed by discussion so that I think
this is really fascinating for their
basically we're sorta playing like a
real time
half video game have acted out real
people
response being too something pretty
horrific
so I'll start with just the beef
level thing is this inevitable is a new
going off in 10 varsities
anywhere not just the united states is
it just ultimately inevitable that this
will happen let's hope not I mean I hope
the idea is that
diplomacy communication things like that
can prevent
a nuclear weapon a nuclear bomb from
going off in 10 varsity
the thing that I found really
fascinating about this was Chancellor
Merkel mmm
thinking that this was such a strange
being party's leaders to be doing and I
found that as a 1% and whole areas
because
women we sit around watching guys play
video games think black
it has no real-world application with it
going to
help you achieve we're do anything in
you got Chancellor Merkel
in this situation it is man playing on a
tablet in this kind of war game scenario
thinking this isn't what we really need
to be focusing our time
energy and attention on is a war game
video game going to prevent this from
going off I would say no I don't think
that this is necessarily
gonna be the way that we're going to
prevent it from happening but I I I
think
I would like to think that it's not
inevitable and that's a very rich
colored glasses way of looking at things
that
I don't want to live in that kind of
fear yeah week 11 that if you're
actually that's a pretty great visual I
picture now Angela Merkel as the mother
and all the rest of the guys downstairs
playing video games get outside and
crazy kid
I what is it inevitable that this kind
of thing I mean with the way dirty bombs
in that now it can be done in a suitcase
all that is it inevitable
no matter how much they prepare that one
day this kind of thing is going to
happen
so I when I first heard
Brock say that I thought I can't believe
that has happened already
and then I thought about it a little bit
more and I really like that well
member they tried to have a couple
terrorists in an SUV
in Manhattan right and they could even
get the Bergen it should be bombed the
blow-up
right to this guy basically got a
firecracker as Carney can't get it to
work
so and then there was the guy with the
bomb on the plane he couldn't get it to
work in
so I'm like I think even if they do get
a party but they probably won't get to
work they will get we have looked out a
couple times right with yet with the
shoe guy in the underwear guy things
that don't
a really work out what do you make Obama
saying this though the way
shockingly that bizarre because he is so
measured
yeah and controlled so it's one thing if
he truly is in
that concern about russia i think thats
okay with a let diplomacy work
but the idea but he just suddenly out of
nowhere said well you know our most
important city it might be destroyed by
using sorta
out of character for him as it like a
strange political may have it in my mind
it was him trying to take the focus off
job rush hour of if Peyton of up what's
going on all along with the criticism
that he's getting for his
Foreign Relations his party it was just
like oh let me say the craziest thing
possible that are scare the shit out of
everybody
was what I think that was my first
instinct reaction whenever I heard
him say that because suddenly if you
hear the president say that then your
fear
goes in a different direction yeah i
cant I thought about like Walton
what are the people in New York thinking
when they hear that you don't be mad if
your kid in school
and the president on TV said a word
about someone blowing up New York where
the bomb what the f are you kidding me
should I be scared all the time
president saying in nineteen I thought
there was a responsible with him to say
it like that would scare the shit out of
people
living in there and i also think it's
plain that whenever they call it a dirty
bomb
yeah it is and it makes me laugh a
little because you know my parents
always castigate me for swearing in my
comedy some like the Miami so carried
away
at sounds like the bobbitt is coming all
the way it's going should check it if
you could get it back bar
I I everybody'll yet yeah
that attorney Bob Baum look obviously
we're not privy to all the stuff that's
going on with these games or what's
really going on with who has
nukes and all that kind of stuff and
scientists that you know defect from
countries all that
but do you think these games actually do
anything cuz they were doing the three
years this isn't the first time they've
done this kind of thing
but it makes me think if a new course to
go off somewhere
it let's look at america per second that
they went up in Paris about that
do you think the games would actually
matter didn't go in
for olympic bench freedom fries you
still have every right to
I'll do you think the games would mean
anything cuz I feel like there would be
such
chaos in such a cascading effect the
blue to see that not a bit
things that they're doing with really
would really matter I couldn't agree
with you more
yesterday we try to plan for nuclear war
her
fields player played plan for when your
head blows up okay
let when what should I do after my head
blows up well first you put a a bandage
around
but no it so I think it's all you want
in a clear bomb goes up at six games
over
I don't you think I do yes they teamed I
mean they have to get the app now you up
their religions but they they hijacked a
plane
including two buildings in New York and
we invaded Iraq and Afghanistan
what do you think if someone goes off
about how well so we're gonna strike
somebody with a nuclear bomb
yeah I mean it that one goes off it
really seems like a domino to me
yeah well that is a good point because
it one way out of here we wouldn't
somebody with nobody
within a week we wouldn't somebody even
even with Obama who
obviously isn't as militantly say
although that some strange things with
drones will get later
as as but arm it so is this just really
like
you know every science fiction movie
ever seen where humans are just gonna
destroy the air
ever gonna have to go the final easier
more on mars or something is that really
where we're all gonna this
I i think a lot of people would say yes
I think a lot of people would say that
humans have been destroying the Earth
since humans became human enzyme
this is just a a quicker way going to
ensure that women
okay edgy step today
where you're at. what you think is this
in humans are we gonna just do it
ourselves between greenhouse gases
global
climate change in everything else and
yeah well I wouldn't buy property in
Florida
yeah I'm not I don't think we're gonna
make it past twenty fifty
I don't think we have to worry about so
secure your running out of money I think
we're not going to be dead before I
don't say miami is gonna be underwater
like there's
people don't really yes if i'm saying I
one bike property in Florida and
you know the whole thing people forget
like Syria what's happening
in what destabilizing the whole region
is a drought
that all started because if the drought
and people came into the city's protest
thing
and then the police overreacted it
started this whole thing soul you know
they talk about climate change having
political political impact it's
happening right now
right it happened lorena something
that's what we should really yelling
about
I'm focusing on because thats much
larger problem and something that's
really happening I mean we should be
necessarily thinking about playing a
game and wondering what would happen if
a nuclear bomb went off
we actually have something that like a
nuclear bomb that's going off
consistently that's causing huge
problems it just takes a longer period
of time
you think we have some progress around
here we started with the nuclear war we
brought around the climate change I
there you go